hello everyone and welcome back to the
1972 World Chess Championship match
between Marissa city beat Spassky and
the Robert James Fisher for those of you
that have been with us for the past
let's say four to five months might even
be following this Fischer saga from its
beginnings now I do have a photo here
it's a print screen of the first video I
did in this saga its Robert James Fisher
versus Robert him not from the Palma de
Majorca intra zonal in 1970 as you can
see all the way to the bottom-right I
uploaded this video it was published on
17th of July 2018 so it's been some four
months in this Bobby Fischer saga and
this is in fact the last game in this
saga it's game 21 and so far the
previous seven games have been wrong
which is the highest amount of draws
ever in a world chess championship
series Botvinnik versus Petrosyan was
six draws in a row and then Spassky
versus Petrosyan was also six draws in a
row but now Fisher versus Spassky now
has seven draws in a row and this will
be the final game which Fischer doesn't
mind because he his three points in the
lead it's eleven and a half to eight and
a half and although he is trying to win
every game but he really doesn't mind
all the drawers and it's something
Spassky will discuss in length later
with his seconds and also with the
Soviet Chess Federation how they
completely had a wrong approach in the
first half of the match because Spassky
was reluctant to go for his favorite
King's pawn opening pawn to e4 and
rather tried everything else but then
only in the other half of the match he
played upon to e4 and here he really
created better games and better
positions but unfortunately he couldn't
win them he he wanted to beat Fischer
where basically where Fischer was better
but now it is a well it's still not too
late but very unlikely
Spassky has the white pieces and again
he opens a with E 4 and Fischer although
he doesn't mind a draw he welcomes a
fight so we have c5 Knight to f3 and e 6
so Fisher again
refrains from DC
which he played already in this match
but we all mention we already mentioned
that it's basically a theme of this
opening for further not to repeat
opening lines Easons by Fisher would
have d4c capture snide captures and now
a six we have the con variation of the
Sicilian and it's a very interesting
Tigran Petrosian played this variation
against Fischer in Game seven of their
Buenos Aires candidates match in the
1971 and Fischer won a brilliant sit
there with the white pieces but
interestingly fishery in that game
played Bishop to d3 here Spassky with a
different style of course decides to go
for a different idea Knight to c3 and of
course it is very likely that Spassky
knows the game Fischer brilliantly won
against Pat Rosen in Buenos Aires but
okay
nice to see six with Bishop to e3 if
nice captures for example Knight
captures here B captors and c6 and now
Bishop to d3 d5 will be excellent for
black as he does create a very strong
center here and has nothing to worry
about
so Bishop to e3 we now have the time out
of the variation on the board and not
Knight to f6 Fischer doesn't go for this
usual Queen to c7 set up a rather he is
ready for some clashes in the center
Bishop to d3 by Spassky and now d5 and
here we have e cap force on d5 and the
official replies with he captures on d5
this proves that Fischer came really
well prepared as there are a lot of
things to consider here for example
instead of E cap choice on d5 Knight
captures on d5 is not really a problem
if Knight captures on d5 then if
nightcap force on d5 Queen captures will
be excellent for black but if instead of
this Knight captures on d5 you have
Knight captures on c6 first then D
captures on c6 and then Bishop to d4
will be very nice for white as it really
controls
this diagonal it will be somewhat too
difficult for black to develop but you
know that that's why it facial refrains
from it so we have e captures on d5 and
then our castles by its paws key Bishop
to b6 and here already you can see that
it can get very dangerous this
- sighing dh2 pawn you know some ideas
like 94 Queen h4 could be possible the
light-square bishop is also very strong
and expose his King side sure you have
to be careful
nightcap resin c6 by Spassky there is no
other way for Spassky to activate his
bishop pair he wants to place the darks
brush up to d4 and really increase the
control of the dark scores on the board
and here be Capra's and c6 although
interesting Bishop captures an h2
doesn't really do anything here if King
capture snide g4 check white can either
go back and black will not be able to
continue in this attack or white can
just laugh in blacks face and play Queen
captures and g4 there's nothing to do I
mean if you capture the Queen you lose
the Queen as well rota captures and as
you can see what is up too much material
white is up to pieces
that's okay B captors on c6 you know we
have to cover everything
Bishop the d4 now Spassky improves the
position of his dark square bishop and
now comes castles if c5 immediately
trying to put back this dark square
Bishop then Bishop captures Queen
captures and now you can really simply
either grab here or go Queen to h5 but
it doesn't really do anything for black
after Bishop to d4 we have castles and
now comes Queen to f3 and here comes a
Bishop to e6 by Fischer again if you
want to take advantage of this Bishop on
d6 by playing Knight to g4 with ideas of
either capturing an h2 or a4 white
prevents this you can still play nice to
h2 this comes with an attack on the rook
and on the Queen unfortunately for black
it doesn't work because Spassky has
Queen to h5 now with the threat of
checkmate on h7 after you prevent this
weather you can go g6 but Queen to h6
again you are threatening checkmate on
the dark squares you can see spassky's
bishops are really excellently placed
and after you block this now you can
simply go rook fe1 get the rook out of
harm's way and with all of this pressure
against the black King white will
eventually win this game so after Queen
- if III we have Bishop to e6 and now
comes look F to e 1c v now challenging
spassky's bishop but now Bishop captures
on f6 Queen captures on f6 there is
nothing better
captures pawn captures and now rook a to
d1 and all of a sudden Spassky realized
as AG legalish mentions in his book that
although it was a con Sicilian later
transposed into the tamaño variation you
have an endgame that is very very
similar to an endgame that arises out of
the classical Scottish opening sorry
Scott opening so came my rook F to d8
Bishop to e2 now increasing his attack
against the D d5 pawn rook a to b8
attacking the B to pawn and now b3
Spassky blocks this if Spassky tries to
grab the pond with Knight captures and
e5 then simply Bishop captures and the
rook cannot capture because of course a
bunch of characters on h2 opens a
discovered attack against the rook on d5
rook a to be eight so b3 first you have
to not allow the rook to capture on be
to c4 and now Knight captures on d5
finally we have Bishop captures on d5
and now interestingly Spassky is well
already this is game 21 Spassky can
really afford another draw with the
white pieces so he decides to give up
the exchange and it's a very dangerous
exchange sacrifice row captors on d5
push up captures on h2 now King captures
and now we have rook captures on d5
Bishop captures on c4 attacking
Fischer's rook on d5 and now if you see
the position here
Spassky has a light square Bishop which
is very strong and he controls the pawns
on the Queen side very well he has a
rook and he has five points whereas
Fischer has four points in two rooks but
his pawn structure is not all that great
with the double F pawns a an isolated h1
and an isolated a sex pawn but the best
way to defend is to attack and this is
exactly what Fisher does rook to d2
attacking the c2 pawn and DF to pawn
Spassky decides to grab be a sex pawn we
have Bishop captures on a6 rook to c2
now capturing upon and now rook to e2
you have to exchange one pair of rooks
and then the bishop will be able to
control all of the pawns on the Queen
side
rook captures Bishop captures and now
rook to d8 Fischer of course is hoping
to be able to get rook to d2 in but
Spassky is ahead of him he plays a four
we have
- D - now only attacking the bishop and
now Bishop to c4
now the B troponin a defense da for pawn
the bishop control defends the pawn in
b3 and the point of course defends the
bishop so not a lot you can do here but
you can capture the f2 pawn but Fischer
doesn't and this is very interesting
Fischer plays rook to a2 and it's very
interesting because fish are over the
board and this is a world chess
championship game so you can be pretty
sure that Fischer played it to the best
of his abilities legally in his book
mentions that rook captures on f2
doesn't work because Spassky can start
pushing with a five and then after rook
to a2 you can simply play a6 the point
is protected and now after black would
try to get his King into the game you
could start pushing your beep on and
after King blocks you can put the b-pawn
again rope or capture but then a7 will
win you the game as after you block it
b6 guards the a7 point and whatever
black plays b7 you have to connect the
passed pawns on the seventh rank the
rook really doesn't matter you will
capture it and then white gets a queen
into the game but it's it's very
interesting that rook captures an f2
after a five can be met with the rook to
be too seemingly a move that both
Fischer and licorice missed it's a very
nice engine move engines always ruin
everything I know but here after rook to
be - it seems that the white is without
a move now whatever you do there for
example a6 as you do wanted this pawn as
close as possible to the queening square
now after Queen King to a fate you can
simply what it doesn't really have a
good move if you play King upon to a7
you can simply block the pawn and
there's no way to defend it because it's
on a dark square and while your rook is
on B - you can never push this pawn as
White will black will simply be able to
capture it so there really is no good
move here whatever you decide to do
black black will be better here but okay
rotate to the move Fischer played he
doesn't allow as passkey to even start
pushing his a pawn here we have King to
g3
came to f8 Fischer of course also once
the ring is going into the game King to
f3 before you you can start pushing your
own points you
have to before you can enter the
position with the King you do have to do
something about these pawns King to e7
by Fischer and now comes g4 a move that
will cost Spassky very dearly the move
he should have played his g3 and then
starts to move his hing and then try to
improve the position of his pawns but
here he played the g4 and Fischer takes
advantage of this move perfectly
he plays f5 and f5 is an excellent move
because it challenges the g4 pawn
immediately now it doesn't matter what
you do if you push the pawn then Fischer
will play f6 and then effigy capture
scheme captures you will have created a
passport
all the way on the Kings side if what
was played is played and it was played
in the game which is G captures on f5
then f6 taking away these nice squares
from the White King and also you have
now created a passed pawn on the Kings
side rush up to g8 attacking the past
pawn but doesn't really matter if it
were simple plays h6 now we have King to
g3 and now comes in to d6 King to f3
we have rook to e1 and now comes King to
g2 Fischer's threat was rook to g1 he
wants to cut off the King completely
from the past bond and then simply start
pushing it so King to g2 you do have to
prevent this we have came to e5
attacking the f5 pawn and now Bishop to
e6 is defending it so as you can see
it's not all that clear how do you win
this yes black is better but the bishop
is guarding the f5 point the b3 pawn the
b3 point is guarding the a four point
and the King is guarding the f2 point so
it's not all that clear how do you do
this we have came to a4 by Fischer and
now comes Bishop to d7 White has to be
careful and not to run into some sort of
a two-prong rook to be one attacking the
b3 point we have Bishop to e6 defending
it and now look the b2 and now it seems
that Spassky is indeed into twon
whatever move he makes will in some way
the deteriorate his position here as
Paschal played Bishop to c4 offering the
f5 point to Fischer but let's explore
some other ideas what what happened
if you just move the king up and down if
if you do this well first of all you
don't really have anything if you draw
this game but let's see what happens if
King g1 then comes h5 kingi to h4 Kings
you won now King to g4 a5 White has to
play something and then comes came to h3
butter up the c-4 you do have to prevent
the rook to be one as this will be
checkmate so look to be one check rubber
blocks kink 2g for you you make room for
the h4 pawn and now after a six I will
simply play King captors on f5 and again
a White has no moves you will then
capture the a6 pawns and slowly but
surely capture everything and then win
the game on the other hand after this
rook to beat you by Fischer you could
try a five immediately but it doesn't
help you
rook to a5 attacks the a5 4 B 4 and now
rope to a for all of the pawns around
the dark squares you will either capture
this pawn or if you start pushing the
pawns you will capture this pawn and
again there is very little you can do
rush up to d7 rook captures and now
after a six you will simply go back
Metro pass the block or if a 7 rope to a
1 you will lose the pawn either way but
Bishop to see it okay you can guard both
pawns this way but then locate one White
has to make a move now comes h5 White
has to make a move if if by any chance
he plays came to h4 then look to H 1
will be checkmate so instead of this
came to h4 you could try came back to h2
but - then rook to a3 cutting the King
off our King has to go to g2 now comes
h4 engage to rope to f3 now threatening
the f2 pawn king g2 and now h3 now we
have King - H - now Kim to G for
protecting the h3 pawn Kings to g1 and
now Rock the c3 threatening rook the c1
and also to capture the bishop so after
Bishop to b7 rook to c1 check King moves
and now comes Luke to f1 and now it
doesn't really matter
for example a7 rook captures King to h1
and now came to g3 there is no defense
against either queening or rook to f1
checkmate if y decides the win to bring
the Queen into the game den Broek to F 1
will be checkmate
and these are just some of the lines
after this look to be to that forces
possibly to do something that he doesn't
want but okay
like we said mush up the c4 he offers
the f5 point the Fisher and fresh
replace look to a two again he declines
the f5 point he that he just doesn't
want Spassky together this a five and a
six move in Russia back to e6 and here
Fischer played h5 and this is the last
move Fischer played before reaching time
control this is move 40 and it is a move
that doesn't work best because it allows
Spassky to go for a certain type of
defense but Spassky did not seal the
absolute best move here the absolute
best move
well the best move for Fischer would
have been King to g4 and this is
something that glitch also mentions in
his book first you want to take the h3
square away from your king well you want
to take all of the squares away from the
White King but the most important one is
the h3 square and only then start
pushing the pass pawn the more fresher
place in the game there's better this h5
move doesn't work because it's fast he
can go King to h3 and now give up a DF
to pawn and after Fischer captures it
now after you push a five rook to a two
now a six you give up that pawn as well
rook captures on a six now you have King
to h4 you no longer have rook to h2
which was the threat of checkmate
so now rope to a seven King captures on
h5 rook g7 cutting the king of the G
file but now you will not be able to win
this with black as the bishop controls
all of DF by D a five point and the b3
pawn and you will simply go up and down
with the king of course you have to be
careful that you don't get checkmated by
black but you should not be able to lose
this game
such is the example but like we've
already mentioned after this H five
moves basket did not seal the absolute
best move the scheme to h3
rather he played Bishop to d7 and then
in home analysis he decided not to even
continue this game so the game was over
here and with this victory Fischer is
now four
in the lead it's twelve and a half to
eight and a half and since this whole
World Chess Championship in 1972 between
Fischer and Spassky was thought out to
be a 24 game match with fish for
reaching 12 and 1/2 points it is no
longer even possible for Spassky to
equalize so why did he resign well it's
very interesting we could show a
variation let's say King to g4 taking
away the h3 square as Spassky did not
play King to h3 himself let's say Bishop
- c6h4 now rush up to d5 h3 check King
to f1 and now look to a1 with check King
to e2 and now you can start going with
the King over to the Queen side but more
importantly you will at some point play
h2 and h1 and promote this pawn to a
queen let's say King III now comes h2
and white really doesn't have a move
here you can't push any of the pawns
because your pawns will simply get
captured this is definitely a threat
which will win you the bishop and the
white can't even make a move like King
to d4 to try and give up a piece for
example if black would push here and
then white might want to hope and that
his King and to pass pawns will be
enough because black can simply play
rugby one check after King moves
captures captures and only then promote
to a queen with check and it will all be
over
so very interestingly after this Bishop
to d7 move Spassky resigned and it's
also very interesting that Spassky
called the chief arbiter lost our
Schmidt he told him I will not continue
this game but it's interesting also
later at the closing ceremony of this
world chess championship match Bobby
Fischer has asked Spassky why did you
resign you know that game still had some
fight in it and suppose he said that he
couldn't find any ideas that would in
some way or off offer him a victory but
it doesn't really matter in this game a
draw is just as bad as a defeat he is
possibly neither the victory he couldn't
achieve it and he didn't fight and find
it in him to hope for a blunder from
front fascia so but it's interesting
also that when water Schmidt
the fish told Fisher that's possible not
be continuing this game Fisher just
asked him that he signed the score sheet
himself and then a lot of Schmidt
replied no he didn't he just called me
and he said that he will not be
continuing and the official requested
that until Spassky signs the form
himself that he will not consider this
match to be over but then after a lot of
Schmidt explained the Bobby that a
signature from chief arbitral author
Schmidt Worth's much more than a
signature from Spassky then Fisher was
finally convinced and finally he
understood that he now became the
reigning World Chess Champion so him a
lot of interesting things here I do I do
suggest for all of you to read
everything I've put in the description
below also diary by Nikolai Kroger's
it's a translation from Russian in
English but it's really really amazing
he mentions a lot of things here like
Bobby and Bobby said that he he would
really like to play championship matches
like every year what he what about if he
hated the most was when Soviet
grandmasters want to watch a
championship and then they held like a
favor said they hid in a cave somewhere
and then you haven't seen them for three
years he said that now that he became
world champion that now he really wants
to play chess as much chess as possible
and he wants to be challenged as often
as possible and really you know get the
chess on the on the main lines also the
port above the board is also a very
interesting one Fischer will win by
twelve and a half to eight and a half
and will be world champion for the next
12 years something Robert Burns said
while he was playing the alien memorial
in 1971 in Moscow which is correct
Fischer did win twelve and a half to
eight and a half but unfortunately well
for those of you who may not know this
Fischer will not be world champion for
the next twelve years but we'll have to
wait for a different series to cover
that and also during the closing
ceremony it's also very interesting at
least to me feed it feed it president
dr. Matsu and former World Chess
Champion offered Fischer his check
the hundred and fifty thousand dollars
check and and oh he was waiting he
offered him his hand and was waiting for
Fisher to shake his hand
but Fisher first studied the check very
carefully and only after he studied that
hidden shook the fee the president's
hand and I went off to eat a steak and
also very interesting he he folded his
cheque into pocket size and put it in
his pocket which is also something
vastly von Schuch is known for doing so
while he was eating a steak you know he
finished eating his take his steak he
was invited for a dance by an unknown
girl from Iceland and everyone was
amazed that not only did Fisher accept
this invitation to a dance but he was
also a very skilled dancer but it didn't
last very long favor returned to the
table like very soon and then max over
offered him not over him but he started
talking with him about the possibilities
of a rematch in Las Vegas next year is
he said that Las Vegas was offering 1
million dollars as a prize fund for the
for the rematch which was very very
weird also something Nico like row gives
mentions in his diary as because it was
against fede regulations you have to go
through the entire world chess
championship cycle the intra zonal the
candidates matches and then to challenge
the world champion so this was
completely against video regulations but
it was something Kruger thought that
maybe max uber was trying to enforce on
to feed a which would perhaps keep
Fischer as champion for for a very long
time
but iam like I said a lot a lot of very
interesting things in the hanukkah like
Rocky's diary to check it out also
something I thought was extremely funny
was an imaginary conversation between
the President of the United States Nixon
and Bobby Fisher of course which never
happened but it's something Nicola Crowe
who says that and the conversation would
go like that if it ever happened also I
will put a link to that in the
description below and also for the end
of the
amazing series I do have a nice photo of
you this is bobby fischer in iceland i
have no idea of the backstory behind the
photo
he seems to be very cold and he seems to
be covered in some sort of a chess chess
board blanket although not really but it
does appear to be something they they
had that was similar to a chess board
blanket if any of you know the idea
behind this story you know do share in
the comments that expand everyone's last
knowledge and also although Fischer won
this World Chess Championship match he
is not the only hero of this match here
is also another hero of the match this
is chief arbiter a lot of Schmidt who is
congratulating Bobby Fischer and his a
great victory over Boris Spassky also
for those of you who were with us
from the beginning you know that Fischer
didn't even qualify for the Interzone
all tournament in palma de mallorca in
1970 because he didn't even play the US
championship but it was due to pal Benko
deciding to give up his place in the
intra zonal and to a couple of other
very convenient factors that fischer was
even able to play this whole candidates
series so there we have it chief arbiter
lot of schmidt who who did not only was
not only chief arbiter for this match of
the century but also served as a chief
arbiter in the match between Viktor
Korchnoi and Anatoly Karpov until later
in a match between Anatoly Karpov and
Garry Kasparov so although an excellent
player and the Grandmaster himself one
of the first players to ever achieve the
title of Grandmaster from fidei he was
more known to be as as the chief arbiter
but yeah like I said it would be
impossible for me to share all the
interesting knowledge you know you but I
recommend in any book or anything about
this match you can get your hands on you
know just to go through it you will you
will really enjoy it so that's basically
it also I mean a lot of you may have
formed different opinions about Bobby
Fischer throughout this whole series
about you know him nagging about the
audience did the cameras the
the money did everything but a lot of
things everyone knows even to this day
is that no one ever did anything similar
to what Bobby Fischer did here and that
he really took the plane conditions
ended the prize money that that can be
earned in chess to a whole new level
never before even even dreamed off by
chess players so hopefully you enjoyed
the series that has lasted for like four
or five months really really do hope you
enjoyed it I really enjoyed making it
and learning more about it but yeah it's
it's not the end of Bobby Fischer saga
we're still gonna cover some of his
earlier tournaments and while he never
got an official rematch with Boris
Spassky he did get one twenty years
later but as I'm sure we'll cover that
match as well now we're gonna talk about
that a bit more and for those of you
hoping to see some other challenge or
challenge Bobby Fischer for the title I
have some very sad news for you but
we're gonna get to that as well so now I
would like to think that David Preston
Micah Wagner Simon Johansen Tim Hess and
Mario Lobo for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check too
on my previous videos here thank you all
for watching and I will see you soon
hopefully with some interesting content
the World Chess Championship 2018
between Carlson in Caruana
as here in in about a week will also go
through some of your suggestions and
also I will start a vote on my next
series after the World Chess
Championship ends in November thank you
all and I will see you soon